[Musica]
ciao a tutti sono tornati global
challenge slime muti senza allenze sono
passati fa volevo dire tifosi viola
allora come per la safety challenge noi
abbiamo pari di quelli qua nella ruota
in base al numero che ci capita
andremo a prendere lo slide
corrispondente poi andremo a mettere gli
stand che si capitano nella nostra
secchielli il cerchio e alla fine che
abbiamo finito di per scarti di slime
dovremmo mischiarli tutti assieme quelli
che abbiamo nel secchiello e come sempre
vince chi avrà lo slime più bello e con
i soloni sr domanda sì ma abbiamo sulla
impulso nenti fatti con qualche materia
allora cosa non lo so perché alcuni di
questi 32 sono molto vecchi potrebbero
essere un po di show libris caldo o
potrebbero essere insomma strani
particolari anche questa volta è tutta
una questione di fortuna e ovviamente il
sì si mostrarono verdi
allora dove ti fanno dire molte cose
episodi di hitwise muti lasciate un bel
haj che se questo video antichissimi rai
quindi visto che siano astenuti sibella
cioccolato cioccolato sono piattaforme
cessato carta cornice foto carta fornite
cazzo carta fallite dai team otto
d'europa
[Musica]
sailer numero 61 beh questo è quello
punto gigantesco oddio protetti
oddio che sarà in modo che il conto di
successo anche questo era scrive nino
campionato perché ingredienti stand di
cosa sono quelle cose fossero reali
penso che sia nei pon pon
oppure lo zucchero filato pontello lo
devi toccare si fa duro
si no in che senso cina lo vediamo con
diventato glossy indurite un po questo
quindi possono aiutare allora poi
batterlo vento se chi è non si fa il po
king perché molto duro nel mondo devono
ammorbidirlo trama tirarlo un po si
stampa forse perché spazzola così quindi
vediamo come diventerà mischiate per
niente line e uno rai uno spruzzo per
colore drammi giallo arancione di clay
dai veti la vecchia è aizzato primo
tratto di lei non vedono nel vedere come
diventerà detto che un bravo che fra gli
capita
[Musica]
siamo 4x4 che soprattutto il riflesso
questo che mi è capitato con dal cliente
ancora tu che sei il massimo lo stesso
agosto grado di mostro vita e
l'amatissimo davvero bellissimo questo e
rosa e il viola sotto era questo il
bellissimo sfumatura rosa proprio nei
quali una sorta di gala
[Musica]
wow
macché color stupendo e questo mi
dispiace pure mischiano bello questo
misti colore rosa i viola è stupendo
[Musica]
proprio bastano tre stelle tarantino che
voglio mischiare troppo bello
[Musica]
davvero bellissimo
andiamo ora a metterlo il secchiello
bella base viola che sto come diventerà
poi speriamo che mi capite modo i bei
colori così facciamo destra tv slime
all'area di rotta by malattia congenita
[Musica]
numero avuto quest'anno si è gigante
logico anton è nato il colore però è
molto particolare sia verde che viola
non mi convince che come
wow in pratica c'è sembra che sia calato
un po tipo la balance il viola corner
poi mi piace mai sentiti rumori
wow
[Musica]
vediamo ora qualche cosa insomma in
questa sostanza nonché le conchiglie
rosa bellissimo quei pochi un appello
siamo dentro pensa a sera un pochino
sica tempo ci troviamo tutti i giochi
eletto secchiello in altre norme
il mio vecchio ne andiamo arancione
giallo
sfumato viola e verde lo sappiamo già
chi vincerà imberbe merda questo l'ho
fatto io tra l'altro questo ordinata lo
ricordi anche che sia per un mega poking
vediamo che vi capita lo scambio sceglie
l'altro quindi tu devi tenere per me lo
sbarazzo di uno questo mi sembra
abbastanza schifoso ma anche meglio
anche questo credito dare alla squadra
un po più presto del numero 7 è il
gigante ma è nerissimo e sapete che
degli slums un teaser in nero in genere
quindi letto tutto molto scuro
questo è un plus trasparente ea
tantissime stelle sotto l'ombrello sotto
guardate un po quante stelle quanta
decorazione se sono questo flybe c'è di
tutto veramente conchiglie glitter
stelline frutta quella questo bravo
tecnico ci sono le facili e ci sono le
letterine è troppo bello magari il mio
dimetterà un galaxy gigante
[Musica]
lo skipper non è vero
una galassia un pianeta diverso con una
superficie sai che ho fatto per questo è
un po perde però questo era una
challenge è lo stesso sicuramente perché
vedo un occhio
in genere gli occhi non li mettiamo noi
di nostra spontanea volontà
si ricorda chi ha fatto questo slime un
buon odore lo zucchero a qualsiasi
livello
[Musica]
non arresta il colore dove dire che è
una sorta di bird e scuro non so se si
beve ma entro bene e quindi la mole
pensione dei perdenti conflitto che
bello però bellissimo perché le cose
dentro
[Musica]
quindi consisterà nel mio blog
quindi mi colori ora sono rosa viola
sfumato e
nero ubertino però non è
anche cosi allora ed ingrosso vediamo
proprio di camere che noi abbiamo uno
due tre ecco l'inter perde poi nessuno
di cambiare ma dobbiamo farlo per forza
buona cattivo quello che cambiamo dopo
questo questo è più bello recato
trasparente o colorato coloratissimo è
un ben giocate vediamo un po
[Musica]
numero due
non ci credo nemmeno me la dà lo slime è
anche un bel live che una zuppa di pollo
e patate sembrano la zuppa di quattro
bellissime allora vediamo un po come
questo ben verde sotto allo stesso quel
po di decorazioni almeno decisamente non
è stato fatto con la con la trasparente
perché mi sembra con la bianca o almeno
di le creazioni sempre un budino un
pochino alle verdure molto particolare
mi piace si è intuito un po qua dentro
perché
ci starà siamo quel riempire del tutto
il secchiello tra l'altro sezione
un'altra coperte ha però perde diversi
50 abbiamo giallo con sfumature
arancioni viola verde e meno e verde
pisello
questo è il verde porro e patate la
terra in palla ma ma grasso da traino da
pescare 1 il 3 e il 5
[Musica]
vediamo non voglio il san donà ha già
detto che segue come mi piace ma che
efficace sul feltro scelto problema che
è lucidissimo
[Musica]
venature puoi vedere foto come
e pieno di decorazioni voi finito
tessuto pelle dura come questo il mare
come sera lo slime oceano che tutti i
sedimenti sotto la sabbia ma è stupendo
[Musica]
che strano tenerlo in mano qui il futuro
il mio l'acqua delle onde bellissimo ma
che belli che abbiamo mai fatto non so
che l'ha fatto io sicuramente un valore
veramente che booking che vittorio fata
ci posso credere nemmeno io
io ho scelto bene ha detto non smette
più di bari foto viene troppo bravo a
strato qui
orbene slime il mio ormai non lo volevi
dare adesso ce l'ho io no 5 del numero
32 slime a meno che non capisca io ho
qualche contatto
[Musica]
adesso mi piaceva proprio che fattura
all'ultimo momento non stava che vi
bello gigantesco odio ben nota altissimo
è troppo bello
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ricapitare scambio ma è riuscito semi e
l'altro e si comincia sei stato cattivo
come tribale numero 3 mi dispiace ti
becchi questo così impari io la neve
fitta per l'attenzione anche dei glitter
e clippers fanno benissimo nell'hotel
con la neve finta perché ai super
morbida mi piace non mi piace la
consistenza bocchino decido carlo
cattivo io solo il vizio non solo
vendicata mani vero niente
che strano
scherzavo non ha voluto toccare non mi
piace la novecento non mi piace anche
quella vera però
capite come lo staff al mandolino
tecniche torta pasticcere pasticcione
all'ultimo turno secondi a un solo un
numero qua se esce un qualsiasi numero
prendere il numero 5 ma se sono altra
cosa tipo scambi se li era altro curiosi
dovrò fare colazione bene vediamo magari
giorno guerra quindi posso prendere lo
slime dietro questa slide ma sicuramente
non è trasparente per non ero io ora
sono molto grossi da noi un viola scuro
sta il famoso viola grigio ha tra
l'altro del sito stesso il violente del
mio team e io sto bisogna un po
[Musica]
betty la fea tutti molto dell'ostello
realizzato il bel
[Musica]
ora si sa come tante sfumature tante le
decorazioni poi nero verde scuro con
tantissimi clip poi celeste mare e poi
viola metallizzato
scrivete nei commenti secondo politiche
color diventerà il mio fly bridge dopo
vediamo ora il tour completo quindi
abbiamo giallo viola attraverso un altro
verde hanno poi verso il pisello e neve
finta celeste secondo me di che colore
diventerà quello di vitale scrivete ora
nei commenti io dico verde ti dice che
se c'è il verde il celeste verde chiaro
il giallo verde scuro e il mio viola
scuro e arrivato il momento di
mischiarli non vedo l'ora allora inizio
io pensai un sacco ora non ribalto
ribaltarlo così non c'è
devo tirarlo contatti con la balestra
gigante ma che figata è un budino enorme
vita espandendo sempre di più la mia
mega torta prime
vediamo un po ora come diventa mente
schiappa è bellissimo immergerci le mani
dentro sica non abbiamo ora una bilancia
per portarlo ma veramente pesanti
scappare costruirlo enorme
e poi guardate i colori cioè tutte le
sfumature rosa e viola stupendo
ecco le norme ci stai facendo
penso che stia diventando più come il
mio team
vediamo
[Musica]
ok ragazzi
penso che il mio slang sia al completo e
alla fine è diventato un viola
metallizzato
meno male ho paura che diventasse nero o
grigio invece è bellissimo perché
proprio un bellissimo viola metallizzate
che voto gli date da una 10 sia per
l'aspetto che per suoni
ecco il mio pronti giriamo mai allora
meglio di no con la spatola pancia
gonfia ottino questi colori loro futuro
che sopra è proprio il mondo perché
allora quello col clay tra black delle
sfumature che chi vince adesso vediamo
di che colori vetta
magari ma tutto carenza nella sensazione
questa neve finta ancora un pancake
gigante nel fuoco ovvero mischiamo di
che bello questo qui questo questo qui
nella consistenza perfetta quella folate
5 così rischiamo mischiamo mischia
e difficile molto duro non è stati
vedervi che quello diventa bello però
così multicolor
sì questo di una piace mi piace tanto
perché 7 muri portoni bellissime sì
stiamo facendo il pane e pasta del pane
wow è molto duro questo qui velo
perfetto auto verde mi sembra che
vediamo nel sonno mi devo sembra un
predetto bestie colori petto e poi
facciamo maria chighine una coperta di
swipe traggono è capitato a me molto
strano facciamo i muscoli adesso con
questa slide enorme alla fine avevamo
predetto bene che il mio sarebbe
diventato viola e il tuo verde
incredibile the sun è vero che sopra
allungabile lo dico solo io voto da the
blind di vitale dai dietisti a fare
aspetto che per su dieci perché
allora il mio sembra la superficie della
luna o tutti i crateri e mio sembra uno
stagno al sondaggio in cui potete notare
fioritto io ti in viola ho capito vitale
kim rossi dove borsa votate votate
e se volete vedere un episodio come
questo lasciate like adesivi l'alexa
devo fare il secondo episodio è ora vi
lasciamo a quattro batterie su cui
cliccare il nostro speciale sul video
divertenti i nostri animi nostri
esperimenti cliccate su quella che
preferite